Good morning John; it's Wednesday, and you
know what that means, I am not gonna play
a song.
Yes 2010 is over and that means I will never
sing another song again. No more song Wednesdays,
no more songs. It's over. Of course I am lying
to you I couldn't stop writing songs if I
wanted to.
In lieu, lieu is a funny word, too many vowels.
So instead of another Song Wednesday song,
I covered a song on my second channel and
you can go watch it. There's an annotation
at the end of the video.
Okay everybody I want you to listen to this
and picture the man who is saying it in your
head.
"When you're listening to nothing but the
best of oldies you're listening to Magic 98.9"
Now I want you to look at this and picture
what his voice would sound like. Now I want
you to watch this as your mind shall be blown.
"When you're listening to nothing but the
best of oldies you're listening to Magic 98.9"
Was your mind blown? If it wasn't it's probably
because you already saw that video on Reddit
or some other way.
But let this be a lesson to all of us, the
way we look does not have anything to do with
the way that we sound, or the way that we
are. We like to think so, in fact we like
to think so so much that we tend to dress
up like people that we're similar to. We all
kinda wear uniforms, like I go to Old Navy
and I'm like "I can't wear that shirt, because
I'm not that kind of person. I'm this kind
of person..."
What shirt am I wearing right now, I don't
even know. I'm the kind of person that doesn't
know. I'm wearing my own shirt. Hahahaha.
So I'm that kind of person.
But another great thing about that silky voiced
homeless man is that the video went viral
and he's actually been hired to be an announcer
for a basketball team and they've given him
a house.
Of course we should all know that silky voiced
homeless man was first to admit that he was
not homeless because of some circumstance
outside of his control. He was homeless because
of alcohol and drugs.
So let this be a lesson to you all. Even if
you have an amazing skill, you can still screw
it up big time.
In other news, John your "*headdesk*" shown
here-"AHHHHHH headdesk!"- was lame. Let me
show you how to really do a headdesk.
AHHHH headdesk. The trick to a good headdesk
of course is the mouse pad. Additionally a
good actual thump with your fists, for the,
as they call it, Foley effect. That's what
we're about here, movie magic, good special
effects, and if you're not behind that 100%,
I don't know if I can work with you anymore!
You headdesked and you couldn't even hear
your head hit the desk! Pathetic.
But I need to have something to headdesk about.
Luckily, I just came across this advertisement.
"The sensor soap pump dispenses soap touch-free
to prevent the spread of harmful germs." AHHH
headdesk.
Oh, a, why do I care if I touch it if I am
invariably going to wash my hands afterward?!
AHHHHHH!
The only use for this thing is to fill it
with vodka and have it automatically fill
your drinks, and as silky-voiced homeless
can attest, that is also a bad idea.
Now finally we move on to the last part of
this video that has had absolutely no theme
at all. In which we shall discover weather
or not our strategy has been successful, and
see if Google is autocompleting "is hank green"
to "is hank green..." AHG no it is not. Wait
what's this, bing, what's bing? OH MY GOD!
Bing got it on "is h!"
Okay, I mean I'm not gonna say anything bad
about Google, because they run this video
sharing site here that I, sorta love. But,
y'all, seriously get on top of this.
Now let's see if they've got anything for
"hank green is" Ohhh, "hank green is cute"
YES! Now of course we have to check "john"
oh, oh, ahahahahaha. Well for this purpose
at least I have to say from my perspective,
haha, bing is better than Google.
I don't have anything else to talk about,
Oh look! It's a video of a lovely lilac/iris
opening. I did this with my new garden watch
cam thing that my parents got me. Isn't it
awesome? They got it from Think Geek, which
is the only place I ever want people to buy
me presents from again, and I only say that
because I buy everything that DFTBA Records
produces. So if you buy me a present from
DFTBA Records, uhm, I already have it.
Speaking of DFTBA Records, we just launched
a new version of our website, it's gorgeous.
What should I do now? I guess I've decided
to go running. Oh that dog is angry at me.
I'm just running down the alley so you can
see our beautiful winter wonderland.
John, I'll see you on Friday.